[Music]
hello so the idea is to be present
suffer France the region so you will
have four starting plan fide right
minutes and it will be served with a
liquid has a lemon for mortal so you
will have some little purse I invite you
to bite into it first so it will refresh
your palate and then you can okay
getting into the into your dish why do
you think French food is so much better
than any other food in Europe it's
difficult for me to to to to to answer I
think that you have a cultural tradition
in France it was always at the center of
the the life it's a kind of art of
living enough de vivre in France and
perhaps not the case in other European
countries where the food it's a
necessity
mr. Baron no one isn't supposed to talk
about politics or religion over lunch
but I wondered if we might talk a little
bit about cannot you see when you are in
gastronomy in front you have not the
right to speak politics on origin when I
am in the club they saw in Paris the
route I'm not to speak about politics
and so on because it's to control
offshore so we try to avoid yes I'm sure
I'm sure
and it is that always up for me thank
you so much thank you thank you
oh that looks amazing
you see Wow yes the presentation it's a
very spectacular yeah and I have to have
the lemon first so I will follow the
recommendation sir perhaps we can taste
and after I will be at your disposal so
you eat like this every day
No
be clear with you know because I cannot
I don't run through and how long are you
here for in in this how long will you be
at the Embassy more than one year enough
okay before I was in India Lizzy in
Paris and before I was more in Treasury
CI I have many friends in London because
I led the French Treasury and I led the
French Treasury when you're a current
governor the governor of Bank of England
Connie Connie was head of the Canadian
Treasury you're in good company and I am
in good company
fantastic and then you will follow up
with a canon of lamp the lamp is coming
actually not from province but from
Wales because we and the Ambassador
agree with me we really like the Welsh
lamp and it will be served with some
kind of vegetable get also all province
or vegetable are into that ghetto this
looks amazing mr. ambassador but you
will see you see it's a sustainable ways
meat but the meat is Welsh and as you
know the best lamb is from Wales and we
ordered Islam in a specific farm in
Wales and today we are lucky to have
this lamb but two weeks ago we asked the
same land for every dinner but the
farmer explained it was reserved for
Prince Java and for prince away so you
will have the lamb of the print shop
fantastic thank you thank you cheers
Cheers
so steep my producer his wife and his
family will along with lots of other
friends will come to my house in the
country yes and then when we've eaten
Steve plays the guitar
so anything guitar with songs or
classical guitar it's an oasis and the
Beatles and no yeah I have not my mobile
phone on me but you will see after the
runs I have all the Beatles on the
Rolling Stones and I have all the French
songs okay I'm not an intellectual and I
prefer the songs and meeting like very
much and you are the popular music for
me it's very very important yeah do you
prefer the Beatles or the Rolling Stones
ah good question my feeling that was the
bitters are more in line we are how I
was 21 century 21st century 21st century
they done the stones right except things
are still alive and all the Beatles
aren't know I know that that you you ask
me it's more compatible with the with
the I seem that the there are all songs
are more in there our mood today and but
further just erm my favorites song it's
her she's a rainbow
and the desert lavender and faith ki get
because the season is just starting and
get reminds us of Gaia so again suffer
France yes true berries and then sabe
with black olive oil I'm going to press
you if I may mr. ambassador on politics
yes
how does Europe view us at the moment
because we have been a family for a very
long time and we want to leave that must
be a challenge for the rest of the 27 we
reread this decision because we are a
family and especially friends because I
heard many many times that friends are
the others no we are the same family and
in the family you can have quarrels you
can have difficulties you can have we
have but we are from the same family I
will take some examples it's no possible
to to ensure security of Europe without
the UK it's not possible to have a very
strong defense without the UK we cannot
work against terrorism without a strong
bilateral relationship between France
and UK so and it's also very important
and we mentioned on the economic side on
the food on the train and so on it's UK
it's a very important partnership what
do you think about Britain
asking the UK asking Europe for an
extension because we have said we want
to leave we're gone and then we can't
get our own house in order so we're
saying could you maybe give us a little
bit of an extension for a while you see
an extension it depends on what because
we need to have the purpose from
from the UK is it for referendum is it
to heaven to prepare new options in
terms of the relationship and what is
the purpose of the extension what do you
think the biggest risks are for Europe
and for the United Kingdom separately
for by leaving the European Union the
main risk it's about the International
influence of the UK and the European
plays throughout the world because we
are in a world which is dominated by the
relationship between the US and China
and you can have two very powerful
countries and it will be more difficult
for Europe to have a place and for the
UK to maintain its influence throughout
the world but my main concern as
ambassador it's to maintain very strong
relationship whatever are our
differences between UK and France
because in all the responsibilities that
I had in my life it was at the center of
the strategic life and the economic life
just want to finish on break say I'm
really sorry but obviously politics is
is your area of expertise and I'm
absolutely fascinated I was a little
girl when we joined the European Union
and now we're about to leave one of the
main concerns that a lot of people
expressed to me it's security they're
worried about the degree that we have we
fall out with our family and friends and
neighbors but we don't go to war with
them what would you say to that I think
that on security we need to maintain
very strong relationship to ensure
security because it's not only in the UK
that the security program is simple
so for me but it's a personal view I'm
not talking as ambassador it's a very
personal view in terms of security we
need to maintain a strong cooperation
with the UK and what will happen if we
don't I don't know I cannot tell you and
I cannot envisage that do you think we
might still stay I think that it would
be better yes but I don't want to
interfere in the British religion I
respect the choice made by the British
people I have to respect that was
amazing thank you thank you thank you
for my lunch mr. Mercer there